OK, I just got the thumbs up, so we're gonna go
ahead and get started.
So hello everybody. Thanks
so much for being here today.
Really appreciate,
um, yeah, I mean it's Thursday
afternoon after what has been kind of a marathon week,
so I appreciate you hanging on till the end.
Uh, my name is Cameron Stewart, and we are
here to talk about reimagining software development
and DevOps with Agentic AI.
Um, so without further ado, let's go ahead and get started.
So what we have on deck today is we're
going to do a bit of a refresher of
what DevOps is. It's actually feels like it's
been a few years since DevOps was like
one of the hot new buzzwords. It feels like everything's
agentic and LLMs these days.
So just a quick refresher, trip
down memory lane,
um, and then we're gonna talk about the tools and technology that we're
using today, how we're empowering developers
to, uh, move faster, to generate
code faster, and then we're gonna talk about the other
tools that help support and make that all possible,
that throughput.
So that's what we have in store. Let's
go ahead and dive in.
I think I first wanna start with what DevOps
is not.
So often people conflate DevOps with
a tech stack,
tools, right? DevOps is not tools,
it's not YAML files, it's not pipelines.
At its core, DevOps is an ethos,
it's a philosophy.
DevOps arose in response to dysfunction.
Because we had disparate teams that had different
incentives and KPIs. We had devs
that were focusing on velocity and getting features out the
door fast. We had ops that was responsible
or rely, um,
was responsible for reliability and making
sure that things were available. We had
security that was responsible for,
well, keeping things secure. And then we had
testing. And quality,
um, and QA that was just responsible for quality
and maintainability all up. But so these were all
different teams that were using different tool
sets and everything was fragmented and siloed. And
so that dysfunction, that bred
dysfunction, and that dysfunction
bred
longer release times and broken
feedback loops and slowed things
down. And if we think about
kind of the early literature of
the DevOps movement, we think about
books like The Phoenix Project and Lean
Thinking,
those were really going back and relying on the principles
of manufacturing. And if you think about a factory
floor and how smoothly things need
to run. A,
um, just a, uh, delay in any
one specific step along that
process causes a delay throughout the entire system.
And so what it was focusing on was optimizing the
system of a as a whole and not
just focusing on a single component.
And so it's applying those same principles
to software development, to the SDLC software development
life cycle. We need to optimize
the system as a whole. We need to give teams
common tools. Of practices about
our culture
so that there's not a culture of of blame
that it's kind of shared collaboration shared
incentives and so that's
really what DevOps is is the union
of people,
process, and technology to continuously deliver
value to end users
because of course technology did
arise right to support these
principles and this philosophy like I said
to support this culture
you know. You know, we did
see things like
CICD and IAC
and GitOps like arise,
but those
weren't
what DevOps was.
They came or they arose because DevOps
demanded reliability,
repeatability, faster iteration cycles.
Those are the things that we needed, and so we
had to come up with the technology to
support these
processes.
Because you can still have pipelines
and be deploying to code and using Kubernetes
and that's not DevOps if developers
can't deploy
frequently, if there's still committee
or change by committee, and
if there's still kind of broken cycles in
there, that's not DevOps. So it's really a combination
of the culture, the philosophy, and then of course
there are technologies that come together to support
and underpin all of that.
And so I do wanna address the elephant
in the room. It feels like this gets this topic
is being brought up more and more these
days. The first elephant in the room that I want to acknowledge
is that Thomas Domka sadly is
no longer the CEO of GitHub, so formally
known as, uh, CEO of
GitHub. But one thing that Thomas always talked
about was we will always need
developers. Developers are going nowhere, even in this
day and age where agentic AI
and co-generation tools are,
you know, are in the future, you know, could be generating upwards
of 90% of. The code the developers are
writing, it could be written by AI,
but that 10% is still so
important, and developers will stay in
the loop. Developers are going nowhere. They're needed
now more than ever, and that doesn't just apply
to the human developers. That applies to
the fundamentals, the little things
using small batch PRs, linters,
code scanners, code review.
None of that goes away. All of that becomes even
more important in this day and age where
we're generating code at such a fast
clip.
But in the kind of before times,
even before
generative AI tools were around, developers
were only spending a fraction
of their time writing code. There's
so many, so other still so many
other concerns that they were focusing on in terms
of
debugging, testing, going to meetings, coordinating,
making sure. That the software was flowing
through the system
easily because again if we go back to those
manufacturing principles, that's what DevOps
is all about
how can we allow maximum throughput? How
can we allow software to flow through the system
with minimal friction and obstacles along the
way? That's ultimately what we're trying to achieve at the end
of the day.
And so going back to, you know, developers were only
spending a small part of their time actually coding,
but there were all these other concerns that they
were also having to focus on.
And that even gets magnified
in this day and age when they're
being when they're able to offload kind of the
writing of the code to these other
tools because when we're generating
so much code at again such a
fast clip there's so many
other pillars of the SDLC that are
still just as important and if
we don't have the processes in
place to support all these
other aspects of the SDLC.
All of kind of this, um,
you know, innovation that we can realize with AI is just gonna
become complexity very, very quickly
and so if we think about kind of the pipeline or the hose,
if we're starting at the front end and just allowing developers
to just generate codes so fast
and it's rocket fuel and they're innovating and they're pumping
out features like never before,
but the rest of your process isn't able
to support that,
that's gonna become a bottleneck and again that's
what the whole
manufacturing principles. And DevOps, um,
you know, arose from is to remove those
bottlenecks because it'll stress the entire
system. So we can't just focus on the
beginning of the pipeline or really the kind of the middle
of the pipeline. Let's just generate a bunch of code really
fast. Now we have to think about the
rest of the process.
And so now I think we're really moving from,
you know, we're in the age of, yes, you can generate code
very, very quickly, and there's a lot of it being
generated at amazing speeds.
But now the process that we need to focus on
is verification and validation.
Now we need to make sure that that code is secure,
that it, um, adheres and complies
with governance standards,
that it has all of the guardrails in
place so that we can have an automatic
flow through
the system.
Because if we think about it,
when we kind of arrived in the AI era,
that was like
just being excited that we had a car.
Now we have an F1 engine, but we need to make
sure that we have everything else in place to
support being able to go at this pace and
at this speed. We need to make sure that we have brakes,
steering. I mean, seat belts. Come on, we
have to make sure that we're gonna stay safe.
And so that's all, those are all the other concerns that
now we have to kind of focus on now that we're
able to go this fast.
So let's talk about if we think
about kind of that front end of the pipeline
like let's talk about the tools that are working that are actually
helping developers to generate this
code. So
if we think about kind of the evolution
of generative AI and the tools that we're
working with, you can think of it and
across a couple of different areas. We're gonna look at the scope of changes,
the frequency of the interaction,
the inner versus the outer loop, and
the developer canvas. And
so, you know,
GitHub released, uh, co-pilot in 2022,
which is a year before Chachi BT
came out, which is kind of crazy to think.
Um, and it was so novel, right, to have coke
inflationss at your fingertips. Now you could
just have your thought kind of finished for
you, or you could have conversational chat
where you didn't have to go to Stack Overflow or Google
to answer your question. You just had it right there
in your IDE. That was amazing,
really changed the game.
And so what we were seeing was like
co-pilot was really good again that co-completion
those next few lines and
when we first uh released co-pilot
we called it your AI pair
programmer. And if anyone is familiar with kind
of how pair programming works, it's that
it's two developers, one keyboard,
one monitor. Both working on the problem
together, super helpful to have that extra
set of eyes there to be like, oh, that's a typo.
Oh, here's, here's the syntax for how you'd wanna
finish that function.
Co-pilot was that, you know, it didn't have to be
a human sitting next to you. Now you could catch
your typos and finish your thought and tell you how to
finish that function definition or what the next function
needed to be.
And so that was really helpful to have that again just
kind of at your,
your uh fingertips and that experience needed to
be really snappy really fast. We wanted to have it
in real time. It really was kind of finishing
your thought as you were actually typing
and this was again focused on the inner loop and this largely
the surface that you were interacting with was your editor,
whether that was VS code or others, but
you were working in your IDE.
Then we kind of evolved to
having conversational chat, being able to make edits
across multiple files. Again, this experience
still largely lived within the IDE,
um, and still focusing on the inner loop, and
this maybe though kind of expanded
the amount of time that it took because some of
the reasoning was deeper. You were asking bigger
questions. It took a little bit more cognitive load
and so this might now,
um, you know, range on the, uh, order of
magnitude of seconds to get a response to you and your
IDE. Then we,
you know, really kind of change the game and we get
to where we're actually handing off entire tasks
to 8. It's not just focusing on a
specific like, here's this box of code.
I wanna be able to do this again.
Can you do that for me? Now we're saying, hey,
I have this new component I wanna make or I have this
new feature I wanna implement.
Can you write that feature for me and
create a new
branch, push it to it, and create a PR
and get up for me?
And the agent can do that and it's incredible
what you can hand off to agent
to an agent and but of
course, you know, again this is a little bit more computation
that requires and so now we're working on the order
of magnitude of minutes
still focusing on the inner loop and this was still living.
Within the IDE
and of course obviously
I work at GitHub so I'm gonna talk about co-pilot a lot,
but you can kind of insert your favorite tool
here. We're not the only player in the game anymore
and there's lots of tools out there that can do this code
completions, conversational chat agents
that can work a little bit more autonomously.
And so now kind of the next evolution
and what I get really excited to talk about
is when we talk about things like
coding agents and so within the GitHub
ecosystem what this looks like is what
we call co-pilot coding agents
and what this uh does is that
you can take an entire issue and you can
hand it to the co-pilot coding agent
and it'll parse the body of that issue,
understand what it is you're trying, like the work
that you're describing, what it is you're trying to accomplish,
and it will. Go to work
and you can assign whole tasks
to co-pilot whether that's increasing
test coverage, writing unit tests. I
wanna implement dark mode on my UI,
um, you know, you can do all kinds of things
that you can hand off to the co-pilot coding
agents
and initially we started with GitHub
issues because, you know, we're gonna start within the ecosystem
that we know and love, but we've continued to evolve
where you can actually interact with and
assign things to. Pilot coding agent.
So now you can do it from, um, Azure DevOps
boards. You can do it from Linear.
Coming soon. You're gonna be able to do it from Jira. You can
even do it from Slack.
It's pretty impactful to be able to hand an
entire task off to co-pilot
coding agent
because what this does, this is completely asynchronous.
You can hand, you can assign co-pilot coding agent
5 issues, and then you can
go to a meeting,
go to lunch, go pick up your kids, go to bed,
whatever it is, go do whatever else you need
to do. And then you can come
back to 5 draft PRs.
It's pretty incredible.
And maybe co-pilot doesn't get
it 100% of the 100%
right 100% of the time, but when
it does do it in one shot, you feel pretty powerful.
You're like, huh,
I didn't even have to fix that bug. I didn't even have to look at
that bug. Co-pilot
knew what the description of the bug was, was
able to parse the issue,
generated the fix, ran tests to make sure
everything was secure, and now we're good to go.
So these are the types of tools that you can
use that can help to automate
this flow of software through the system. This
is just one example again we're kind of focusing on the
beginning of the pipeline. This is helping developers
generate code rapidly
and you know, developers are getting a little bit more
hands off in the scenario which we'll talk about more
um in just a bit.
And so this really is kind of the shift that
we're seeing when we, we started with,
you know, code completions and then conversational
chat, but now we're really moving from assistants
to agents. I mentioned that when we first
released co-pilot, we called it the, uh, AI
pair programmer.
Now what we're kind of referring it to with the
rise of things like co-pilot coding agent, it's
your peer programmer.
You can actually hand entire issues to it like it was a junior
dev on your team,
and so it's less a tool and
more, you know, something that's that can act more
autonomously.
So we're helping to, you know, evolve from
passive agents to more autonomous
or passive helpers, excuse me, to autonomous agents.
So let's uh take a look at what that looks
like. I wanna show you, um,
co-pilot coding agents. Give me just a
second here. We're gonna switch on over.
OK, there we are.
Um, welcome to GitHub. I have
this, uh, repository,
which is kind of like a logistics app
and. And
um, I have a number of issues
here of
things that I can work on. So
we can take a look at a couple of these, um,
you know, explore using a green color palette,
page navigation and keyboard shortcuts,
um, performance optimizations,
add autocomplete suggestions for the search bar.
Um, let me, we will start with this
good first issue. The navigating
to the help center page doesn't redirect.
So again, this is a GitHub issue,
but it doesn't have to be. This can be a linear ticket.
This could be a JR ticket. This can be, you know, you
can describe this from Slack,
um, but we have the details and the issue here. The user
should be redirected to the help center page
when they select it from the bottom. Bottom menu
and then we have a nice screenshot here
and that's all that's in the issue so it's not
um all that verbose but it is
nice. I mean it's pretty straightforward in terms of what we're trying
to fix the screenshot's super helpful and
so what I can do is I'm just gonna go
ahead and assign this to co-pilot
and because so I can optionally
add another prompt where this is. Targeting,
you know, which repository do you want to target? This is the one
we're already working in, so I'm gonna stay there.
We'll talk more about this later, but you don't,
you also have the ability to assign
it to other custom agents. We'll
talk more about custom agents in a little bit, so I'm not
gonna touch that for now. I'm not really gonna add
anything. I think that the issue is good enough as is,
and so I'm just gonna go ahead and assign it.
And so that's gonna kick off this whole process.
Now co-pilot is an assignee. We'll see, we'll watch
it for just a second, because you can see here that I
assigned co-pilot this.
And what it's going to do is it's going to start a draft
PR.
And in this PR.
It's going to say, hey,
thanks for assigning this issue to me. I'm gonna start working on
it. I'll keep this PR's description up to
date. It'll actually post back as it makes,
uh, changes and kind of goes through it, does its
thing, um, and it'll
kind of, yeah, keep you updated there.
Now I wanted to kick this off because this will take.
Maybe 10 minutes or so
we'll see depending conference Wi Fi, you know,
uh, so we're gonna, we'll come back to that so we're gonna let
that kind of cook for a bit and in the meantime
let's go to VS code
and talk about um some of the other ways
and some of the other tools that developers,
uh, have at their. Proposal in order to help
them, you know, generate code and so
again I'm a BS code. I'm gonna be working with a
co-pilot and so one
thing that I have is, um,
again this is a logistics page and you can also
do like a shopping cart thing or you can add items
you can. Add items
to a shopping cart, but we don't actually have a shopping
shopping cart page at this
time to display the items, so I wanna help
have co-pilot help me with that.
So I'm going to say can.
You help me
create a shopping
cart page.
And use the, I
have
a screenshot or an image of what
I want it to look like
as a reference. And so what
I'm doing here, so a couple of things, because
again this is I just kind of kicked this off, this is gonna cook
for a minute.
One thing to call out, I'm working in
agent mode and so with, by
the way, can everyone see this OK? Do you need me to bump up the font
or anything? We're good? OK.
Um, with VS code you
have a couple of different modes that come out of
the box. Initially we started just with
ask and then we added edit and then agent,
and then we recently made plan available
because you also have the ability to create custom
chat modes and the custom chat mode
that literally everyone was creating and putting in
their, uh, repositories was a plan mode
and so we're like. Well this just makes a lot of
sense and everyone wants to use this, so
we're just gonna put this out of the box MVS code
so you can kind of target which mode
you're interacting with. I find the agent mode
is probably the one that I'm
working with the most unless I'm specifically
working on a plan where I'm not trying to generate any
code. I'm just kind of in that ideation brainstorming
phase, and then I'll work on plan mode.
Uh, but you can see that I also have another
list, and these all correspond to other,
uh, custom agents that I have defined
within my repository.
Now how you do custom, um,
customizations with co-pilot, um,
at the repo level is using
the construct of this dot GitHub,
um, directory. And so within that
directory, you can see that I have actions, agents,
chat modes. Instructions, models, prompts, we have
a whole bunch of things in here.
And so I have these custom agents which are defined.
We can see API specialists, TDD green,
TDD red. We have a couple of custom agents
here. You'll notice that that then corresponds
with the custom agents that I see here.
So again, you can kind of target these custom agents
if you have a specific task that you're working
on. We'll go deeper into custom agents a little
bit later, but I just wanted to call that out since you can.
See them there and we're wondering what if you were wondering
what those were.
So if we go back to
co-pilot, we can see that a number of things have
happened. So first it's, um,
you know, saying let me examine the existing
front end structure to understand the
current issue. You can see,
um, you know, what it's using for reference. It's using
a custom instructions file,
um, you can see, you know, the files that it's
reading to understand the repository structure
and how the codebase is functioning.
Um, it's gonna check if there's a cart
context already and look at the
color theme.
Now let me create a comprehensive shopping
cart implementation.
It's telling me what I'm, what it's going to
create. It's going to create a cart context
to manage the cart cart state,
cart page component.
Um, it's going to update the,
um, file to include the cart route,
and it's going to update the products component
to use the cart context.
So it has a number of things. Again, it's gonna kind of. Continue
to work, but you can see here that I'm
handing co-pilot an entire task. Implement this
functionality for me, and it's gonna make changes
across multiple files.
Right now we can see up here it's already,
um, created and is working on those
two files. So that's super
helpful that it's kind of again working on
that now while co-pilot
agent mode is working, you know, of
course there's other things that I can be doing, but
it really has kind of monopolized my IDE
session for this particular task. I'm waiting
for it to complete. It's output
and that's really what I, we're gonna pop back over
and we're gonna check on how our,
uh, coding agent is doing,
um, because what I love about handing off to the
co-pilot coding agent is that it really does feel
like so much more of a handoff. I'm not
quite as involved sitting next to it waiting for it
to do its work. I'm just completely saying,
hey, you go take care of this and I'll be back to check
on you
when you're done, honestly, um, but
we can see that it has indeed kind
of updated the body of the PR now
it's created a plan and it's working.
Uh, it created a list of steps that it's going
to work through, and it's already done two of those.
So same thing,
I'm gonna pop in to kind of
check on the co-pilot coding agent, what
we call a session.
So we have this button here that I can view
session, and what this is gonna do.
So this is going to take me into
co-pilot's session and so
we can kind of see from the beginning. First thing it does, it's
gonna check out the code. It's gonna set up node
and it's gonna start both the GitHub and the Playwright
MCP servers. Now those ones are loaded
by default, but you can also have your own
MCP server definition if you want the
coding agent to use a specific tool or
to use a specific, specific MCP
server, you can configure that. So these are just
the two that are on by default out of the box,
but you can definitely.
A more customizes as you,
um, as your, you know, need kind of,
uh, requires.
So same thing like co-pilot takes kind of a
very, uh, similar path with both of these
is I'll start by exploring the repository
structure, understand the code base, locate
the relevant files for this navigation issue,
um, you know, goes through those various files.
Now let me explore the front end.
Let me examine the footer component and
the app routing structure. You can see the files
it looks at for that.
Now let me check to see if there's a help center component
or if there's a page for that already created.
Now, let me check. It's going to look at our package JSON
and it's going to understand the build and test setup.
It's going to look at the dependencies.
Um, all right, now I understand
the issue. The help center link and the footer
component is just using an HRF
that doesn't navigate anywhere.
So, again, kind of our plan, what we need
to do. Um, so co-pilot's
making good progress here.
Um, we're going to update the footer
to use RA's router link.
Uh, we're gonna run the project. The build succeeded.
OK, so co-pilot is still working
here, but these are examples of kind of two different
ways that you're using, that you're interacting or you're
having an agenttic experience. One is in the IDE,
and that's leveraging agent mode. And again,
this is just co-pilot specific, but there's other
tools out there that give you the very similar,
you know, agent experiences or agenttic
experiences.
Uh, the other is by leveraging
another tool, co-pilot coding agent, that you can
lob something off entirely to
delegate that. Responsibility to and
it'll just work in the background. The output
spoiler alert is gonna be that we're
gonna get a PR with all of this work completed
for us to review. And so like I
said, we'll see, you know, we'll
see what it looks like and how good of a job it did
and maybe co-pilot doesn't get it in one shot every time,
but it at least gets you pretty far, maybe
80% of the way there, and that gets you
a great place to at least
now it's a good jumping off place and you didn't have
to start from there. So we're really empowering
developers to move very, very quickly here.
All right, let's pop over, um,
to back to the PowerPoint while these things kind
of finish.
And kind of continue to talk about co-pilot coding
agent because now I do wanna talk about it in
kind of more of a real use case because
that's adorable little demo scenario that I have
cooked up here but let's talk about something a little
more production grade.
So internally,
uh, we at GitHub
use GitHub to build GitHub.
It's turtles all the way down.
Um, everyone at GitHub uses GitHub sales
folks,
marketing folks,
everything lives in an issue. We track call logs
and out of office requests and GitHub issues that we use
the platform,
um, for more things than it was designed, honestly,
uh, but this doesn't stop at just the platform itself.
It also, you know, extends to the AI
tools that we're also building and so. Our internal
teams,
uh, use co-pilot coding agent
extensively. In fact,
we use coding agent to help us build
coding agent. And during that time, during March,
you can kind of see here,
it was one of the most productive members of the
team. And so it was able to
create new features, but it was also able
to address tech debt, which is really,
really incredible
because like
as GitHub we get an inane
amount of features. Request. I know that you all can relate to
this as well, but there is just an ever growing backlog,
and it feels like you're never really burning it down,
especially with the really annoying nitpicky stuff
like, you know, that does represent just tech
debt in general.
It's the boring stuff, it's mundane.
Developers don't wanna work on it. They wanna work on
the shiny new stuff. There's always pressure
to get the new feature that's actually gonna deliver
business value out the door first. There's
constantly this war between like tech debt,
new features. Protect a new feature and new
features win
every time
and so you know this can kind of be a bit
of a battle in terms of how do we address this
and I'll kind of end with this at the end of the
talk about um how we're handling
this at GitHub, but I just think it's really incredible
that we're using copilot to do some
of those boring things that developers don't wanna do
and it's allowing us to burn down our
backlog and to be more productive
because we're able to offload this to co-pilot.
And so
in for the um
core GitHub repository whoopsies
um.
You can go in and see that
co-pilot coding agent is the #1 contributor
to our core repository that builds GitHub.com.
Which is pretty incredible because it's only been around for a couple
of months and right behind it in position
number 3 is a co-pilot code review agent
and so this is having a massive impact to us
at GitHub. We're using these tools
to really burn down our backlog and to really make commits,
and I know this slide looks really pretty and looks like
it's a marketing slide. So I just wanna prove to you that
this is true, and we're just gonna pop over
to, uh, what we affectionately call GitHub GitHub.
This is the core GitHub repository.
You're looking at it,
and if I go to the insights tab.
And we wait for our contributions. You can
see top committers is what we're calling
co-pilot Sue agent, which was the internal
code name for co-pilot code agent when it first
came out. And if I, you know, adjust this
from one week to one month, like this is live actual
data, you'll see that the, you know, it does adjust.
Here we have co-pilot code review.
So this is what co-pilot looks like actually in the wild.
Like we are using this internally at
GitHub.
Alright, so now I wanna switch gears a little
bit, um, and talk about some of the other pieces
of the AI infrastructure that kind of support the other
parts of the process. It's not just about developers
writing code.
So first, um, in terms
of being able to realize the
maximum value and to get the most
out of these AI tools, especially these agenttic
tools, as we all know, context
is absolutely everything.
We first learned this with how we would rewrite
our prompts. There was a lot of nuance
that could go into what you were asking the tool
to do. And if you could give examples, if you could give
a specific format type or an. Output that you
wanted to see, you would get better results.
Now this has really widened the scope
of this has really widened from, you know, rag
and using other tools to pull an MCP
or using MCP to pull in other tools
to pull in context from other systems. I
mean, really the name of the game is how to give the
most appropriate and relevant context to the LLM for
the particular task at hand that you're trying to
handle and one of the kind of best
practices. That we have landed on and
that is widely adopted throughout the industry is custom
instructions
and so this is your
opportunity to tell co-pilot and other
tools how you want a particular
task done
and what I think is really um
interesting and where some of this nuance is really starting to come into
play is you know you can use kind
of like a top level like we see here
again using the dock GitHub directory.
Um, just a top level co-pilot instructions file
you can definitely do that. But what becomes even
more interesting is then if you
start using instruction files that
only apply to certain languages
or frameworks, so if there is,
you know, whatever for all of your CSS files
you want one set of custom instructions to apply
to those files, but you want a different
set of custom instruction files to apply to
your playwright tests, for instance,
you can use this construct,
that middle construct.
To only apply it to certain file
types and so this is really
important because this not only is
um
you know, taken into consideration when you're working with
co-pilot in your IDE or when you're working with agent
mode but then when you start to do other agentic
experiences like co-pilot coding agent
or co-pilot code review which we'll talk about, uh,
shortly, it will look at these files
and pick up. On this, um, and
use this for context so that you can be
very specific about
how you do things within your organization. What
are your coding standards? What are certain
compliance guidelines? How does code need to be
formatted? What does it need to look like,
especially when you're doing code review, custom instruction
files are gonna be your best friend, and I would highly,
highly recommend that everybody
use this with every repository.
Um, and then just in general if you're just working with
top level agents, you know, you can have different
markdown files that guide that
particular agent again on how
you want it to behave.
So there's lots of kind of customization here.
I do want to show you what this, uh, looks
like, so we'll pop back over to VS
code.
Um, I want to show you
some instructions files.
Um, and so we have different instructions files
for, um, you know, API
instructions,
um, and this is for, you know, guidance
for editing and reviewing API code changes.
You can tell it what it applies
to. So again, just within
these directories and these file types,
um, you can give it kind of the review guidance,
talk about your general API principles,
make sure that it has a, uh, specific
checklist that it is adhering to.
So that any time there are changes to any
of these files that are listed
here,
again, if you're doing something like code review,
this will specifically these guidelines will be
applied specifically to these file types.
The other cool thing that you can put in the Matter hatter
uh description here is you can
put, you know, if you want to exclude something,
so there might be custom instruction files
that you just want co-pilot
code review to look at or that you just
want the coding agent to look at.
So there's a lot of opportunity for
kind of customization and granularity that you can
get with this simple construct of using your custom
instruction files.
And so that's just one,
example.
Um, the other thing that I wanted
to kind of chat about is
using,
um, custom agents. And so
if we have,
let's see,
I think.
That.
Do do do. OK,
so let's take a look at this, uh, custom agent
that I've created, which is an accessibility agent,
and we're gonna see what this kind of looks like in
action. But again, it kind of follows the same
top level structure. It has a description,
so this is an expert assistant for web
accessibility,
um, and you can configure certain
tools, different, uh, MCP servers
that it might want to have access
to and the different tools that it wants to call.
And then again you can kind of give it the
like. Uh, structure of what it is and
kind of what your expertise is and you can help ground
it in the context and in the
approach and this is again is all just
described as a simple markdown file so a ton
of kind of capability and benefit
in a very simple construct and what that
will look like is since I have that
accessibility agent we'll pop back over to my.
Repo for a second. Um,
let's go back to
the pull request. We'll come and check on co-pilot's progress
again in just a minute, but we'll go back
here. And actually, I don't even need to navigate to
the code tab.
But within the GitHub UI and I'll make
this a little bit bigger.
You have the ability, you have this agents panel
and a couple, uh, important things here. One,
you can see all of the recent sessions that I have
for across various agents that are happening.
So we see kind of our, uh, redirect
issue on the help center page that's the one that's
currently in progress,
um, but I have a couple of other ones. What's nice, I
could pop back into any of those sessions to again
see what happened, what co-pilot's thinking was.
This is important from kind of a just auditability
and governance perspective. Also as an org
owner, you can see all of the. sessions
that are occurring within your organization and pop into
them. So again that's helpful from just a kind
of um security perspective,
but what I can do is I
can select from my list of
agents, my custom agent here. So
I'm using the accessibility agent. I still
wanna target this repository. I could go
to other repositories and I'm gonna give it
a um
prompt that says something like ensure
this repo is adhering
to accessibility.
Guidelines and requirements,
and I'll go ahead and fire that
off. And what that is going to do is that's
going to use that custom agent, but custom agents fundamentally
work in conjunction with co-pilot coding agents.
So this is going to spin up another session, another
task that co-pilot is going to work on,
but it's within a very well,
uh, well-defined and scoped. Parameter
this is a specific task
and so what's nice here is any time
you have
tasks that you're finding yourself you're doing over and
over again, create a custom
agent for that. You can see some of the other
examples that I had here for um
custom agents. Let's just start a new session.
And you can see,
you know, I have a compliance bot. I have a documentation
specialist. Like there's a lot of different custom,
um, custom agents that you can create.
And speaking of, if you're like, hm, what are some other
good ideas for agents that you might wanna
create,
uh, I don't know if you all are
aware of this awesome repo called Awesome co-pilots,
but this is a great.
Resource that you could go and look at to
get ideas for um
what are some other good examples for
these customizations that you can take with co-pilot so
you can see we have, you know, examples for custom
prompts here for custom instructions files
for custom agents and so you
can go in here and I bet there is an accessibility
look there's an accessibility agent right there.
Um, so this is really good to kind of
see what are these, uh, custom agents
if you're looking to get some inspiration for,
um,
you know, other agents that you might wanna pull into your
workflow, an APR architect agent,
um,
you know, an Azure specialist, like there's a lot
in here. So definitely recommend that you go and
check out the awesome co-pilot
Repo. Um, it's, you know, open and public
and just a collection of good examples and
patterns that you can use for,
um, inspiration.
Um, so now I'm gonna pop back over to,
um, our custom instructor or our PowerPoint
for just a minute.
So we just talked about custom agents,
and so these are specialized agents again defined and marked
down files, but if you have specific
things that you find yourself
over and over like SEO optimization
is another great example
of where you would want to use a custom agent
because then you can really just point that agent at
a task at your repository and
say. Hey, go make sure that we're adhering
to these, these guidelines.
Again, that's the type of stuff that developers hate
working on.
So if you can avoid developers working on that and offload
it to an agent,
do so. That is the kind of toil that
we are eliminating. If we go back to those DevOps
principles, it was all about,
um, reducing the waste and that
toil that developers hated working on.
And so this is another example of what that looks like
in this AI era.
Um, and so we saw this kind of briefly,
but I would say in this, um,
world where we are starting to see
lots of agents that have multiple sessions
that are working on different things, all of a sudden, while that's
very exciting that we can leverage these tools
to do all those things.
That also creates a little bit of sprawl and
if you're kind of in like the administrative or
org owner role that can make you a little
nervous of how do we have visibility
into everything that's running, who kicked off what session,
who, what agent is running, you
know, what task and so whatever
tool you're using.
Have it be a tool that gives you visibility into
all of the different agent sessions because having
visibility into this, being able to
have some kind of auditability is really important
and just from the developer perspective
to be able to manage all of your sessions is
super helpful.
One thing, um, kind of new improvement that we've brought
to co-pilot and coding agent
is, as we've seen,
you know, a co-pilot kind of has its session, you
can actually now pop into that session. And do
live steering. Previously you had to
wait for its work to complete if you
change your mind and you know something needed to be
the button needed to be pink and not blue, um,
now you can actually do live steering
in the session for co-pilot and you can, you
know, make that quick decision and it'll take that in for
feedback and adjust accordingly. So,
um, the ability to kind of manage your sessions
and then pop into your sessions and kind of steer
is an important capability.
Lastly, some of the tools that you know, you, we
kind of recommend you use, um, MCP,
this is,
um, you know, it's called kind of the USBC
for AI. It's kind of the universal connector
that allows you to bring in context from external
systems to provide to the LLM,
honestly,
now I would say
this is still a little bit of uncharted
territory.
Uh, we at GitHub, we first started thinking
about how.
To integrate again, pulling in data from
external systems to provide
to co-pilot to make it more effective, to bring
your context from your organization into
the chat to make the responses that you're getting
more tailored to your organization.
And we first went on this journey and started with something that we
called extensions,
and that was about 4 months
before that Anthropic announced MCP
and everyone quickly was like, OK, MCP
is the way.
And so you know we also kind of adopted
that and have, you know,
support for MCP servers and have an MCP server
registry and all of that goodness
within the co-pilot ecosystem
and then I don't know if anyone caught, um, about
3 weeks ago anthropically something called
skills
and so that might be a new construct. So I
would say, you know, MCP is still a little
bit of, um, not unproven
technology, but they're still. A lot of question marks with it. I think there's
still a lot of unanswered questions for how we're going
to do this
in kind of a standardized way.
So we'll see kind of where all this shakes
out. For now it's MCP. It
might look a little different in six months,
but for now, you know, this is a really good kind
of path, and there is a lot of adoption
around using MCP as the way to
pull additional data into
your systems.
Um, but it is important to have some governance,
um, in place because, you know, you,
these are,
you're giving tools access to
your secure development environments. There's a lot of
information that they can access and so,
um, you wanna make sure that you're doing that in a thoughtful
and mindful way. You wanna make sure
that they're,
um, able to meet compliance standards and
that you're kind of balanced. Balancing,
you know, the productivity that you wanna get with also being,
um, sensitive to the information that's also being shared
with these tools and so some of the kind of
best practices that you can, um,
deploy is you can use a registry based allow
list. You should always use OO if you can,
um, you wanna be able to define and control
which MCP servers developers are using.
You don't just want it to be like.
Wild Wild West,
whatever tool developer kind of
sees fit for that purpose, you wanna
have a little bit more control over that,
um, you wanna block kind of any unapproved
usage that you haven't specifically said
like yes it's OK to use this particular tool,
um, and then of course always like communicate that
well to developers provide clear,
um, policy messaging.
Um, and one other just kind of piece
as from the like the control aspects
within kind of this AI,
uh, world is the ability to audit
this, um, activity and so specifically
with Co-Pilot we've recently made some
improvements to our audit log for all
of these things that are kicking off and the ways that you're using
Co-Pilott
so now you're able to understand who is.
The kind of user that initiated a request,
what is the co-pilot like interaction
if it's coding agent versus code review
that is hat that, you know, performs the action and
all of this is auditable via the audit log. So
I'm giving you a little bit more
control because you can't go fast
without the proper guardrails in place. And so
this is just one example
of one of those guardrails.
OK, so if we think about
what is the kind of new,
the whole DevOps pipeline look like in this
AI world
today. In yesteryear,
this is kind of what your old life cycle
would look like. You would have an
idea that is born. You'd have a number of developers that
are working on it,
and, the idea would be logged, a ticket would be created
to track that work, uh, you would assign
that ticket to, you know, a
developer, a team member.
There would need to be clarification that would
happen. Sometimes context could get
could get lost. The developer goes on vacation.
You're having to kick it over to another developer,
you know, a PR is initially
opened, reviewed, more feedback is
given another more work continues
you iterate, you iterate.
Finally, maybe you, you know, um, do
some security checks, um, kind
of get those,
uh, taken care of, and then, you
know, you can approve it and merge it sometimes,
hopefully not, but sometimes then vulnerabilities
can even be found.
In production after,
uh, things have been merged and then you're gonna kind of kick kick
that back and address it from the beginning,
but this is what the kind of the old life cycle
looked like and this could range anywhere
from weeks to
months and so if you were, you know, really,
um, a fast moving organization
that had really good deployment pipelines in place, this
could maybe be on the order, uh, magnitude of weeks,
um, but more likely probably in the month
time frame.
Well today it looks a little different and in
terms of who's involved it's gonna look a
little bit different.
So the new life cycle is that yes,
ideas will still be born and that is where
human creativity will never cease
to be necessary
and then you're going to, you know, have some brainstorming
that needs to happen. There's gonna need to be a human
that approves. Yes, this is the plan,
this is the next right thing that. We need to
work on.
You're gonna do some specking. What should this
thing look like? You're gonna need human approval
for that as well.
You can see that we have a couple of humans, but then we
have a whole lot of robots. That is
to signify that could be get co-pilot.
That could be cursor. That could be cloud code. That could
be your tool du jour
of your tool of choice du jour
tool du jour anyway, your tool of choice.
And so you know I mentioned earlier
the developers are not going away. Developers are absolutely
still in the loop, but I will acknowledge that the
role of the developer, really everyone's responsibilities,
is really starting to evolve and change
a bit.
And so I was, you know, talking with some colleagues
and we were talking about, you know, this idea
of specking
and how important that has become
in today. Day and age when you're handing
over an issue to something like co-pilot
coding agent,
your mileage will vary
substantially based on how
well documented that issue is, how
specific you are in terms of what
expected output you expect to see,
um, you know, the test coverage that needs to be required, you know,
any amount of detail that you can put in that
issue. Is the more detail
the better and so specing is gonna becoming
more and more important so developers
are gonna start
becoming better at writing
specs.
PMs are going to become
a little bit more technical and more proficient
and maybe a little less reliant on
developers.
Now a PM could have maybe
3 different ideas for what a front
end could look like. And they have
these designs captured in Figma. Well, they could
work and use the Figma MCP
server and and GitHub copilot, and
they could create 3 different front-end
prototypes. They don't have to go to the developer and say,
Hey, can you wire up 3 different
of these apps so that we can decide which
one looks best? Now they're gonna be able to do that
on their own.
And so everyone's role is going to evolve a
little bit, and I mentioned that.
I don't think we're that far off from
developers, um, seeing that 90%
of the code being written is likely being written
by agents and so they're
gonna be more responsible for understanding
what is this software need to look like, what does this architecture
need to look like, what are the specs and the success,
the acceptance criteria that is, that's gonna be
part of this project,
and I was listening to a talk.
Um, by Brendan Burns, who's one of the co-founders,
um, or one of the original,
um, contributors to the Kubernetes project,
and he was talking about layers of abstraction,
and he said, you know, if you write code in C,
you're two layers of abstraction from away
from the computer that's actually running that code
because C compiles down to the intermediate language
and then that compiles down to assembly. And
so from the developer perspective, like, you're not actually
seeing like the code that's getting executed, that's
getting run
because we have abstraction layers in between us, right?
And so similarly we're now just creating another
level of abstraction that developers are
going to kind of benefit from
because they're gonna be more responsible for architecting
the entire system,
how the agents are gonna coordinate with each other,
but the actual execution, the atomic
unit of execution is gonna happen
with the agent. Like that's just the reality of the
world that we're living in.
And so we will see that, you know, more
and more we're gonna rely on the robots to,
um, take care of this process for us.
But that's OK because again, humans aren't
going anywhere, it's just the nature of the responsibilities
is changing slightly.
And so what we see here though is, you know, after
we've kind of brainstormed inspect, like what is it that we
need to build, we're gonna do some coding, we're gonna do lots of coding,
we're gonna iterate.
You know, oh, we might have found a bug, and
as part of that process of that code being generated.
You want to have as much automation
as possible in place so that it
doesn't slow down again, kind of
become the bottleneck in the overall process.
Remember, we're trying to optimize the ease
of and uh software being able to flow
through the system with ease. And so what we're
looking at is things in there you can see that
it says auto fix, and that's a co-pilot capability
that is able to identify if there's a security
vulnerability that's been detected,
understands what that security vulnerability is, and then can
actually suggest a fix to remediate
that process.
So I'll show you what this looks like within the PR workflow
and how you can use that. But again, if we can rely
on. Agents to help remove these blockers
and not get hung up when we do run into
anything that's gonna be key
because while we do have to ensure that the software that is
getting delivered is secure if
we can automate how that is detected
and then remediated all the better, right?
Put the guard rails in place but let them be,
um, you know, handled by these agents to help
you move fast.
Um, then, you know, kind of continuing down the
process we're gonna be able to do code review that also can be
handled in agentic fashion these days all
the way to kind of we're ready to
deploy again that's gonna need human
approval, of course, just to make sure that everything that's
generated looks good, designs as,
um, intended, that is behaving
as designed and that everything
is secure and adhering to all standards
and compliance requirements.
So I mentioned as part of that,
um, a couple of things. First thing, co-pilot code review.
This allows you to do kind of an engentic
code review, and this is something that you can set up
as a rule set on your repository
so that every PR that gets created
leverages co-pilot code review.
You can even configure it so that it can run,
um, security tools or linters,
and you can have a number of things. In fact, you can even,
oh no, um, we'll see configuring a
linter, um, but so that you. Can have
a code review do a first pass because oftentimes
we see that that's where one of the longest wait times
occurs is waiting for a human code
review to occur and so if you can at least
take a first pass from an agent that's
an incredible benefit to developers to
again not slow down the process to keep things
moving. You can catch things earlier developers
can fix it that's less
manual or that's less um
requirement on the human developer that will ultimately
come in
um and you can help.
To reduce the overall load of what they're reviewing
when they do step into the process.
So you can do a co-pilot code review. Again, you can
do that in an automated way.
You can also do co-pilot autofix. This is what
I described, um, where you're
if a security vulnerability is detected,
now you're able to kind of have the developer
spend less time
fixing those vulnerabilities if you can offload it to
an agent.
So this is something that, um, co-pilot
code agent or co-pilot coding agent can now
do. It has, uh, security capabilities
so that it can do auto fixes and can leverage
our static analysis tool codeQL
under the hood,
um, and you're able to again kind of have an agent
to help you with this process.
So, um, and when you're leveraging,
um, autofix when you're doing this kind of at scale,
you're really able to see, you know, faster
fixes that occur within the pull request.
So catching these things, of course, before they make
it to production, you wanna catch it
in the developer workflow in the GitHub world
we really consider that the PR,
um, these are the, this is the time and place to
catch these vulnerabilities and to remediate them
before it moves any further.
Um, you're able to see kind of 7X
faster fixes for things like cross-site scripting, 12x
faster fixes for things like SQL injection.
Um, these are very common patterns that LM
LLMs have gotten very good at detecting and knowing what
is the canonical fix in order to remediate that
vulnerability.
So again, that's low hanging fruit that we can just offload
to a deve to an agent so that your
developers don't really have to worry about it. Of
course they'll be able to review the fix and to make
sure that,
um, you know, it looks good. Of course you're still gonna
have all of your testing framework. Work there to make
sure that everything is still green and passing
um and so nothing you know everything is still being
reviewed and following best secure practices
um you're leveraging an agent and not having to
take developer time to actually implement these fixes
so pretty meaningful
so let's take a quick
uh look at what that um
looks like so.
If I go back to
my repository, you can actually see here,
um,
I'm gonna go back to another pull request that
I have, not the one that co-pilot just opened,
the one that I had.
Um, opened earlier today and
we can look at what this looks like again. We
kind of see the PR as the
place that a lot of these
processes should occur because this is where developers are
already kind of
used to getting feedback.
They're still kind of actively working, but this is
where, um, you know, code scanning it's
run and any vulnerabilities that are detected
are, um, alerted and notified and
annotated within the PR.
So we can see that we have a number of different actions
that are being run. We're doing a dependency
review to make sure none of our, um,
packages have vulnerabilities
in them. Um, we're also doing a
CI results, um, summary.
And then you can see here that we have this
bot, GitHub Advanced Security bot,
and it's calling out, you know, a specific,
uh, file, and we'll see here
that we actually have an alert
from CodeQL again, that's the technology
we're using under the hood to do static analysis scanning.
And that we have a vulnerability for
uh missing rate limiting
and that co-pilot has a
suggested auto fix so it gives you a high
level description of, you
know, what the problem is and what the fix
needs to be and then
giving you a summary of the changes that that are
required and then it actually gives
you that suggested
fix right in kind of this diff
view,
um, similarly, you'd be making changes to two files.
And so you can, you know, commit right from
here. You can also, you know, open this in
your IDE. It'll take you right to kind
of this fix and the proposed, the, um,
proposed fix from co-pilot. You know, there's
a number of different things that you, a number of actions
that you can take.
Similarly, so we have a lot of, uh, issues
in this PR. No surprise, I wrote it,
um, and so we can see that we have a number of vulnerabilities,
but we have autofi there to help us
out with those vulnerabilities. And so that's on,
um.
Ultimately what that looks like. So that's super
helpful that I'm alerted of that.
If I wasn't within the PR, if the code scanning
ran kind of out of bounds and it wasn't new
code that was being checked in
that had code scanning running on it, um,
oops, um, and I pop over to my security
tab, and I had just security results,
um, just in general. So here we can look at, we
have a code injection,
critical vulnerability.
This is interesting because this is actually looking at our
actual. Workflows and we have potential
code injection in
uh the parameters that we're passing into our workflow
because it could be controlled by an external
user
and so what this is now saying is
that you know using user controlled input and
actions could lead to code injection.
It gives us more information here which is super handy
but what I'm able to do is I'm also able
to generate a fix for this vulnerability.
So again, kind of in terms of. Reducing
cognitive load from the developer, the ability to
do this is super impactful.
But more importantly, what I was, um,
more trying to show was that you have the ability to kind
of catch these things in the PR in an
automated fashion.
Now you also have the ability to assign
if there are vulnerabilities are detected, you
can assign those directly to co-pilot coding agent
to take care of. So there's, that's another
way that you can kind of offload to
the agents.
The other thing that I wanted to show you, I mentioned
we talked about code review, and
so I just wanted to pop into my repo
settings, go down to
um co-pilot and to do code review and
to show you kind of what that looks like.
So we have a
rule set that has been set up that leverages
code reviews. So I'm gonna pop into this rule
set, and this is really how you protect
whether you want it. You can create a rule, uh, rule
set for a branch, a tag, a
release. There's a number of different ways and,
um, interactions that you can apply a rule set
to, um, and you can, you know, um,
specify which repositories you're trying to target, which
branches you're trying to target, and then you
can see some of the rules that we have
in place for to. Protect this
branch, um, we require that pull
requests occur before merging. Um,
we require workflows to pass before merging. We
require code scanning results.
Uh, we require code quality results.
Now we have the ability to do, uh, code
quality with, um,
uh, an agent, a co-pilot agent,
but you can also request the co-pilot
do a code review. And so it could be on
like this will just be on every PR
that is created. You could also then
optionally, um.
Select or elect to have it on
any new pushes or also on draft pull
requests, so a little bit of choice there,
um, and then you can also manage which static
analysis tools co-pilot will use in
its code review. And so code QL is selected
by, um, default, but then you can
also select to include linters here.
So there's a lot that we're starting to offload as part
of the code review process. To
again catch these issues
before um as early as possible to give that
feedback to the developer as soon as possible
so again we're not trying to slow things down
later on in the process we're trying to catch
them much um
further um along.
And so yeah, I think that's
all that I wanted to
show you with code review just that this is
definitely something of best practice that we
recommend that you can, you know, have
this occur on every PR that
is created on GitHub and
so this is, you know, something that I would definitely recommend
that you all look into.
Alright, so we're wrapping up here. We have about 5 minutes
left. Um,
you know, I was talking earlier that we're, we're thinking
about the front end of the funnel, and that's where we have no problem
today. We have so many tools that are available to us
or helping developers generate code,
um, and
before this time, you know,
speeds that we've never seen before,
um, but now we need to focus on the other
half of the pipeline which, uh, is all about
verification and validation, making sure that this
code is secure and that we're comfortable bringing
it into our production environment. And so
just from kind of a. TLDR for some of the things
that we talked about, you obviously wanna have your validation
or your security validation tools. Security
has become more is more important
than ever in this era of generative
AI.
You also should leverage co-pilot code review because
there's so much that you can tailor
within that process. You can pass it custom instructions
files. You can require that it runs
on every PR. You can have it run
security tools like static analysis or
linters, and you can have those things occur
automatically at the PR level as part of the
code. View before a human ever even gets
involved and then you can also use our new
uh quality code quality agent
which will give you a score for things like
readability, maintainability, any quality
issues that are surfaced. It'll surface
those for you. You can have a developer
look at those. You can apply. You can ask co-pilot coding
agent to generate, um, a fix
for those quality issues that are surfaced. So
there's a lot that can, you know, help you
tools that are already available that you can realize
today to help you stay secure in this, in this
space. All right,
so in sum, here's some of my recommendations
and calls to action for you
all to do today,
um,
invest in the primitives. I've talked a lot
about this, but
use those custom instruction files
because they are so
you can be so specific and so granular and so
tailored into what you're trying to
do at different processes, whether that's code generation
or code review leverage those custom instruction
files.
Every repository should have
one. I'm really gonna lean into
that. Every repository should have one.
second, whether it's MC it's MCP
today, if this changes in the future, we'll
see, but leverage the tools that allow you
to pull context in from other systems
to be more effective in using your LLMs.
Secondly, leverage the agents. The agents
are what help you automate
away the toil. It's again, coming back
to those DevOps principles. Remove toil, remove
those bottlenecks. The agents are the
tools that can help you do that.
Then leverage the
processes. So do the code review,
have automated verification and validation.
That's the part of the funnel that we're really trying
to focus on right now. So have those
processes that can help you validate and verify that
the code is good to go.
And then lastly, don't forget about the fundamentals
again. AI does not change any
of the core of DevOps. So
having code scans, using linters, doing
code reviews, having code owners, all
of that, small PRs, frequent,
um, check-ins,
none of that goes away. Those things like
we're doubling down on the importance of those things
in this AI era. So definitely don't
lose track of the fundamentals. And if you're not doing
these things well today, AI is
gonna bite you. So focus on doing
those things really well first.
And so again, just a kind of friendly
reminder because it's one of the my favorite
things to talk about,
we are leveraging
co-pilot coding agent internally and it's really
driving huge impacts in terms of our backlog and
addressing our tech debt.
But
really don't take it from me because I'm in sales,
so, uh, but you should take it from Brittany,
and this was a talk I know it's maybe not
standard to, you know, pitch someone else's talk
when you're giving a talk, but Britney stood up
at GitHub Universe, which is about 5 weeks ago,
and she said, I'm not in marketing and
I'm not in sales. I'm an engineer at
GitHub. I don't even work on co-pilot. I work in
billing,
and she said, I'm just here to talk. To you about
how excited I am, how we're using co-pilot
coding agent to tackle tech debt on
our team, and she gives really good examples
of the tech debt that they're addressing, the ways to
be most effective with co-pilot coding agent,
and it's just an overall delightful talk. So
there's a QR code there. I highly recommend that you go
check out Brittany's talk because she's kind of the
real world, um, experience that
can speak to using these things in a production system.
Um, and that's all that I
have for you. So thank you very much for your
time. Appreciate y'all all being here. Hope you have a fabulous
rest of your conference. Tomorrow's Friday.
Yay.
Uh, thanks guys.